josephus to neo and his friend Kristin
Babic were in the crowd when shots
filled the air Sunday night Babic was
hit in the shoulder the two had to find
a way out of the venue to get to the
hospital
Joseph estudio is with us now Joseph
thank you so much for joining us this
morning first how are you doing how's
Kristen doing she's gonna be fine she
has a collapsed lung she was hitting her
near her right shoulder but she's gonna
make it forward however the doctor told
me tell me what happened at the concert
when you knew something was wrong we
heard what sounded like fireworks going
off but it just it kept going and going
and going we didn't we refused to really
believe it was gunfire
and then when Jason Aldean went off
stage it was kind of clear something was
wrong people started screaming hitting
the ground and running and we were just
lucky we made it out how was Kristin hit
when you were running out or were you
taking cover you know what we're not
quite sure when she was hit she kept
them pointing that in her word she got
hit by a water balloon that's how she
described the experience she was
hyperventilating I thought she was fine
at that she was just panicking but when
she started coughing up blood I kind of
realized that she'd been hit and she
probably had a class long what did you
do I I immediately checked when she
started coughing up what I checked her
body for a wound I looked I felt and we
couldn't find anything at first but we
agreed that the number one priority was
to get outside of the venue
and so were you able to walk outside the
venue we didn't walk we actually hopped
that fence right there
near the national stage was just set up
behind us you jumped over the fence we
we had help there was a table or
something in front of the fence and we
just got on top of that and kind of went
over the fence it wasn't as tall as
people are making it out to be got it
got it got it but and were first
responders immediately on the scene
medical responders were there when we
hopped the fence and this was it in
minutes
Metro did an excellent job getting there
as fast as possible and I really
appreciate everything they did yeah and
what she loaded into an ambulance no not
at first we actually went up to a hotel
right up here up the street and we
checked her again and found the wound
and a Good Samaritan who is that concert
goer she's also paramedic helped us put
her in a truck and then once we realized
that the strip was barricaded we put her
in an ambulance that we found on the
side of the road well Josephus to do
thank you so much for for joining us as
me this morning and please give Kristen
our best as she recovers thank you very
much